Ultra 1050.
he's like Service Road Woodlands Parkway
it's gonna be a golf cart no tag
thank you
good evening
good I'm definitely come with the
Sheriff's Office stops you because
you're driving tag or uh unregistered
vehicle with no tag on it on the roadway
yeah we were we went to the club it was
closed so we went over and picked up
some is your camera on it is
I'm the police chief in Tampa oh how you
doing I'm doing good okay I'm hoping
that you'll just let us go tonight oh
okay yeah I'll say you not to say I you
look familiar so yeah I'm sure I do okay
so all right folks well uh have a good
night
staying over here in East Lake Woodlands
yeah
okay all right well it's nice to meet
you
so I'm Deputy Jacoby okay same here my
friend all right take care of yourself
all right no worries no worries let's
say we have a lot of problem with the
the golf carting around here you know
everybody we don't normally come out
that's the great place to get some food
gotcha okay all right all right then
we'll take care and uh it was nice
meeting you all right oh all right you
ever need anything call me okay serious
all right appreciate that thank you yes
ma'am you're welcome thank you for your
service thank you for yours thank you
take care all right thank you have a
good night folks
pulse region tonight
you too